a lot more time on the clock as well
do you think he's going to win this
i would be very surprised if he doesn't
to be honest still needs a lot of hard
work
and against the queen there's always a
chance you'll lose control but anish
okay he's going on the attack now
lifting his rook up the board that's not
to bring his rook anywhere but it's to
support white's dark square bishop if
white star square bishop can line itself
on the same diagonal as the black queen
and black king it's game over and he can
do that here as well look at the two
players they both leaned back at the
same time
and that's what
giving up the white bishop but if the
black pawn takes this bishop now then
the white rook on the g file is free to
go up to the top of the board and trap
the black king
prague is shaking his head came over
yeah he knows it's over there's nothing
to do he has to give up his queen very
nice game for me i have to say because i
mean even though the computer said that
prague's position was always okay i
think we all agreed that anish's
position was better throughout and he
just kept the pressure on two bishops
won the game
and it's over